[Music]
uh shik Hassan a number of the brothers
have asked uh to se seek some advice
from you regarding the crisis and the
affair that's happening in Philistine
right now if you have some
time uh it seems that now we see that a
number of the Muslims many of the awam
the Layman the general Muslims and
around the world and in our communities
have despaired over the situation and
the severity and the magnitude of the
killings and the destruction that we see
and the Bloodshed that we see happening
to our brothers and sisters there in uh
Palestine may Allah preserve them and
protect them um and they've they've sort
of lost hope in in seeing the the the
affair manifest and unfolding um
and then now we see that many of the
atheists have capitalized on the
situation and are saying things the
likes of which if there is a God you
know and he's such a merciful god and
you claim there's a God why does he
allow this Bloodshed why does he allow
the killings why does he allow these
things to happen to the people over
there so we we're asking your advice
Hassan uh regarding this
affair alhamdulillah all praise belongs
to
Allah
what we are witnessing in
Palestine is something that is painful
and
saddening and even
traumatizing traumatizing for the old so
what about the
young the fact that this is something
that pains the
believer this is a sign of Faith
im as the prophet sallahu alai wasallam
he
said and the
that
ISL he
said the light of the Believers in their
love their
affection and their Mercy is like a body
If part of the body feels pain then the
rest of the body responds with
sleeplessness and fever
so it's a sign of faith that yes we are
saddened by what is taking place these
are our brothers these are our
sisters at the same time alhamdulillah
as
Muslims we
know that everything that Allah subhana
decrees is according to his infinite
wisdom and Allah is the most merciful
the most
just this
highlights what we are seeing in
Palestine the patience and the
determination of The Honorable
Palestinian people in the face of
adversity and persecution and the
courage and determination to try and
live us and live a normal life under
these prison-like conditions is a lesson
for us all and the prophet wasam said in
the
authentic that amazing is the affair of
a Believer for there is good for him in
every situation and this is not the cas
for anyone except the believer if he is
blessed he's thankful to Allah therefore
it's good for him if he is met with an
Affliction he's patient and therefore it
is good for him so as Muslims we believe
that there's more than this
world there's this world there's the
grave and there the
Hereafter those who are
dying from these missile attacks and
Rockets as mentioned
by those who die under such conditions
the ruling is the ruling of Mars
inshal Allah have mercy upon the dead
and preserve the living aan the innocent
civilian casualties in Gaza we hope they
are martys
inshal Subhan
Allah we worry about
ourselves and these are individuals
Subhan Allah that Allah has honored them
in this D some cannot see it
likewise the children in response to the
atheists you look at things just from a
worldly perspective we look at it from
many different
angles the children of the Muslims
according to the consensus of the people
of knowledge they going to
Paradise even the children of the
non-muslims according to a number of
Sals and I hope this to be the strongest
position they're going to
Paradise
also this issue right here is it shows
us the reality of people anyone who
stands by condones trivializes the
killing of children the king of women
can never talk to us about human rights
can never try and attempt to talk to us
about human
rights because that is total
hypocrisy
and he tests us with
things
to distinguish between the good and the
evil likewise Subhan Allah one of the
things I've noticed brothers and sisters
from what is taking place the
inspiration of The Honorable people of
Palestine I've seen so many people
Subhan Allah start to pray that did not
used to
pray so many people that did not
practice the religion as Allah commanded
them to start to practice the religion
as Allah commanded them
to
so many
non-muslims interested in reading about
Islam in reading the
Quran
sometimes we can only see what is before
us but Allah is the all knowing the all
wise and the people they plot and they
plan Allah plot against those who
cunningly plan
no and
remember that no oppressor will escape
Justice either in this world or the next
it's going to haunt them Allah
said do not think that Allah is unaware
what the wrong doers
do these trials and these tests are not
something that is new when
M and the Believers who were with him
when they were faced with genocide from
pharaoh
and he would kill their sons and keep
their women because he was a tyrant like
the other tyrants on the earth and the
tyrants of the earth will perish and
Justice will remain what did M
say he said to his
people seek the aid of Allah and be
patient
this Earth belongs to Allah he gives it
to Those whom he works from his servants
and the ultimate outcome the final
outcome will be for the
Believers
Sor that is something that we are
certain of this is not in the interest
of the oppressors this will come back to
haunt them sooner or later exactly
exactly and it highlights for us as
Muslims the importance of uniting upon
the Quran and upon the Sunnah with with
the understanding of the companions the
S of this
nation because that is going to be the
way that we can address these challenges
it highlights the importance for the
ruler and the Ruled The Young and the
old the Arab and the
non-arab to implement the rulings of
Allah subhana wa
tala and also the fact that when we turn
away from the commands of Allah it leads
to weakness because the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said in
theith
highlighting when people become over
immersed in this world and forget about
the when you dealing
Usery and you become happy with
Agriculture and you take hold of the
Tails of the cows and you leave off the
legislated
Jad not that which is practiced by the
extremist of
Isis other than them that which is
legislated in the Quran and the Sunnah
and exemplified in the sun of the
Prophet
s will place upon you a
humiliation and Allah will not remove it
until you return back to your
religion till we return back to our
religion so there are
signs and there are things even at this
dark
time for us to be optimistic about and
we must have good thoughts about Allah
subhana waala and believe like M he
said seek the aid of Allah be patient
the Earth belongs to Allah he gives it
to Those whom he
chooses but success is for the
pi
days he gives certain days to some
people and other occasions other days he
will give to others but success is for
the
pi likewise brothers and sisters what we
are seeing take place in Palestine it
highlights for us the Excellence of our
nation as a
whole our nation that is a nation an um
that
is because who could be patient with
these trials and these tests and deal
with the level even in the west the
level of
islamophobia and the way that the
Muslims are treated and the double
standards but alhamd the dignity and the
honor of the vast majority of the
Muslims they still conduct themselves
with honor and dignity and they act upon
the principle we obey Allah concerning
you even though you may disobey Allah
concerning us because the premise is
what it is
Justice we ask Allah for success and we
ask Allah to protect our brothers and
sisters in Palestine we
ask to remove from them this
Injustice yeah just to add one
thing and I think I just want to
reiterate from your advice beautiful
advice um in in steadfast and having
hope and good thoughts of Allah and you
mentioned the narration of the Prophet s
wasallam until you return to your
religion and like you mentioned you know
we see that happening we see people now
returning to their religion from those
in Philistine and other than them around
the world people starting to pray people
starting to study their religion stud
the book study the books of of AKA learn
their religion properly and there's this
trend as you even mentioned as well a
lot of non-muslims and it's the same
thing we saw happened in 911 when we saw
the atrocities the the bombing of
Afghanistan and Iraq uh the killing of
people's there we saw that a lot of
non-muslims turned to Islam and decided
to seek an interest in Islam now there's
this trend going around in Tik to and
Instagram and all the social media
Outlets uh where you see people
purchasing qurans going out there and
learning trying to find out what is
Islam because they see the resilience of
the Palestinian children they see the
resilience of the Palestinians in the
face of all this adversity in the face
of killings one uh woman I saw she
mentioned this Palestinian child her
entire family got wiped out and she
still say in the likes
of you know Allah is the best of
disposer of our Affairs and and and and
you know and they see this How firm they
are and is like they they think to
themselves how are these people so
strong what is the faith that these
people have I want to learn about this
and you know Subhan Allah I saw one
Jewish girl um and as well as another uh
Evangelical Christian and the Jewish the
Jewish girl was saying you know people
are turning to Islam she herself became
Muslim she said and you know what people
are going to turn to Islam people are
going to turn to Islam more and more
every day this Evangelical Christian she
went in she decided to read the Quran
she found out that Muslims believe in
Christ Muslims believe in Jesus Muslims
believe in the return of Jesus and it
was something for her it was
mindboggling she said they never taught
us this before so again it's like you
mentioned they plan a plan and Allah is
the best of planners and sometimes we
don't see the bigger picture but
alhamdulillah there's hikma and there's
wisdom in in what Allah Al does allahar
so and no doubt because as well as
Muslims as you said we believe in one
God we worship him alone without any
Partners we believe in all of the
prophets and The Messengers without
exaggeration without falling short at
the same time as well we stand for
justice justice whether it's for us or
against us we condemn 911 we condemn the
killing of women and children anywhere
in Israel in Palestine or anywhere in
the earth likewise we hold the world
accountable to also stand for justice
and look at the Excellence of that like
we condemn the killing of women and
children wherever they are we also
demand from others to also condemn the
killing of innocent women and children
in Palestine is the blood of the
children of Palestine cheaper than the
blood of the children of Israel or the
children of the UK or the Children of
America no their blood is valuable and
it should be honored and it should be
respected and it should be defended but
we're living in a time where Allah if
for in the UK a politician calls for a
ceasefire that he's suspended from his
position it just shows the double
standards and the hypocrisy and that
people they talk about human rights but
they in reality they do not stand for
human rights because the right of a
child for life is something I think any
decent human being can agree with but
sadly we have some who claim to be the
champion in this Arena they can't even
speak the truth and call for a ceasefire
for peace and a solution to this problem
that is going to haunt people for many
days and many years and we ask Allah
subhana tala for Success a mean aan
mustan you mentioned that just quickly
you said um the politician there is a a
uh I remember uh just recently here now
the UN Chief actually called for a
ceasefire and the Israelis asked for him
to to resign so I think one of the
things that is happening and you
mentioned this as well in the advice
again that uh this affair is exposing
people it's exposing people on both
sides of the coin whether Muslim or
non-muslim those who you know in their
hearts and it's one of those things I
believe it's a you know it's a sunah
ornah from Allah that FNA exposes people
trials and tribulations exposes people
and we're seeing people people's True
Colors now a lot of the the the people
who stand for human rights and so on
we're seeing what they where they where
they stand in regard to this uh to this
affair I mean I've mentioned
publicly a few times in lectures and
also you know in a few posts that
extreme rhetoric that we see we see
extremism on both sides of the aisle for
example you have people that are saying
now that no one in Palestine is innocent
because they elected Hamas so therefore
they are all guilty but that is the same
reasoning as Isis Isis they argue that
every
Western civilian citizen is a legitimate
Target whether a woman or a child or an
innocent regular civilian because they
elected Western governments no and as I
mentioned then and I'll say again now
two filthy sides of the same Otten coin
but like you said that's another wisdom
that these type of events saddening as
they are expose the reality of people
and what they try and claim about
themselves being fair being just wanting
peace and other than that and Scholars
mentioned that and I mentioned the verse
when Allah
said Allah distinguishes between good
and evil
and
said many people are exposed at time
said something similar he said that
these and
Innovations Expos many of the creation
and he
said and it remove the veil and Expos
corrupt and Despicable foundations and
fundamentals n so it's a test you know
and it's bringing to light many
realities and again Allah grant us all
firm us and may He allow us to speak
that which is correct and that which is
just and may He protect us from falling
short or going to extremes
now I mean definitely you see extremism
you know appearing Subhan Allah in ways
that you would never imagine like for
example the call for one politician uh
when he said that uh Palestine should be
nuked you know and they should drop
nuclear bomb upon Palestine which is
Subhan Allah which is alarming to the
extent that he was even removed from his
position so you know extremism is not
something that is you know specific to a
particular religion like some people try
to make out you know that it's only a
problem that Muslims have to deal with
no we see many extreme faces we see
extreme ideas in India we see extreme
ideas in China we see extreme ideas here
you know in what we are seeing taking
place in Palestine and again
alhamdulillah we close with that may
Allah grant us all success and protect
the
Muslims